The force awakens does something that
fundamentally changes how we understand
star wars or rather it should
fundamentally change how
we understand star wars.
Strangely,
the filmmakers seem unaware of the
rather profound implications this new
narrative has for the rest of
their cinematic universe. In fact,
one of the major plot points in episode
seven inadvertently sets up something of
a storm trooper paradox.
Can you explain what I mean by that?
I want to focus in on two scenes near
the very beginning of force awakens that
signal.
This shift in the star wars myths.
First we see a storm trooper bleeding
or a franchise about intergalactic war.
Very little blood is ever shown on screen
and when it is,
it holds a special significance.
I know
in this case the bloody fingerprints mark,
this particular soldier,
Portland
Second,
a short time later,
we see that same storm trooper take off
his helmet to reveal a human face and
one clearly disturbed by recent events.
The removal of a mask to expose someone's
true humanity is a recurring motif in
the star wars series.
And we've seen hundreds if not
thousands of storm troopers before,
but we've never seen one with a face.
Both of these scenes communicate that
under their iconic Armour storm troopers
are people,
people with feelings and who feel
pain both physically and emotionally.
The result is that the force
awakens does something.
No other movie in this long running
franchise has ever done before.
It humanizes storm troopers.
Do you understand why this revelation
is so important and how it impacts the
rest of the star wars mythology?
We're going to need a quick history lesson
in the star wars cinematic universe.
Stormtroopers are the army
of the galactic empire.
They're an intergalactic military force,
synonymous with space,
imperialism and oppression.
They're said to be brutal, precise,
and loyal soldiers who have undergone
extensive military training on these last
points to lack good at
presenting to people.
Only imperial storm troopers are so
precise now despite their role as foot
soldiers of authoritarianism.
Star
ahead,
there's happy, calm, some of the most
recognizable pop culture icons on her.
The name.
Storm trooper is borrowed for special
divisions of German soldiers during World
War One translated from the original
German. These soldiers. Yeah,
we're known as storm that
they were aggressive and
heavily armed assault troops
organized into companies
known as storm troopers.
Store man would later
become a paramilitary rank
in the Nazi ss under Adolf
Hitler
in George Lucas is much maligned prequels.
The predecessors to storm troopers are
introduced in the fall of the republics.
Clone Army
soldiers were made to order fighting
machines all sharing the same genes in the
same face.
They are totally taking
by the time the original
trilogy rolls around,
clone soldiers have been phased out in
the ranks of the new imperial storm.
Troopers are made up of
conscripts and volunteers are now.
Fast forward to episode seven and the
first order also uses regiments of storm
troopers.
Here we're told that many of them were
kidnapped his children and brainwashed
into loyal fighters.
I'm a storm trooper.
I call him.
I was taken from a family I'll never know
raised to do one thing.
Essentially their child soldiers,
which I think is especially noteworthy
considering the only storm trooper face
we've ever seen belongs
to a young black man.
Every other storm trooper has no
face, no name, and no individuality.
They are completely dehumanize
across eight feature films.
They're portrayed as little
more than disposable grunt.
Yes,
ten two one eight seven or Finn as he's
eventually known in episode seven is the
only exception. Finn is an imperial
defector who joins the resistance,
obviously. Yes, I am with.
There's just as, yeah, I am.
What's the resistance?
He's funny. He's emotional.
He's brimming with personality.
You're a pilot. You can fly
anywhere. Weigel back. Got a family.
I've got a boyfriend to boyfriend.
None of your business. That's why
not exactly the characteristics you'd
expect from someone kidnapped and
brainwashed from an early age,
but setting that aside,
Finn is the only storm trooper out of
presumably millions who we see develop a
conscience.
Are we to believe he's the only one
with the ability to resist first order
programming? Well, no.
It's possible for other soldiers to
reject their conditioning. In fact,
the first order has a protocol for
exactly this kind of noncompliance.
N Two one eight seven proportion to
my division was evaluated and central
reconditioning.
No prior signs of nonconformity.
This was his first offense
and yet fin rebels.
Anyway,
pins very existence stands in contrast
to the rest of the storm troopers in the
force awakens.
I mean on the one hand we have a likable
humanized storm trooper who switches
sides and on the other hand we have
all his fellow storm troopers who the
resistance kill without a second
and this is why it feels like the film
has a confused dissonant relationship to
one of its own plot point.
Why it feels like it doesn't really buy
into it's own premise because if Finn
can remain so very human despite
years of programming and conditioning,
then that must mean the same could
be true for all other storm troopers.
Unfortunately,
the writer's responsible for this movie
don't seem at all interested in pursuing
any of the morally complex questions
that arise from this fact preferring
instead to indulge in more action scenes
built around blasting more mindless
automatons.
Can I try that?
In fact,
blasting stormtroopers has become so
mundane that it's an end universe.
Jokes often played for laughs.
I like this thing.
Stormtroopers are framed as easy to kill,
both literally and figuratively
and they are killed
a lot
over the course of the force awakens
two hour and 15 minute runtime.
We see a total of 68 storm
troopers, shot, stabbed, vaporized,
and those are just the ones
that we can see die on screen.
Again, these are child soldiers
that we're talking about here,
which is even more reason for the film
to at least acknowledge the underlying
tragedy, but there are
circumstances but it never does.
I mean it's easy to imagine a more
emotionally complex plotline perhaps
something that focuses on a group of
disillusion storm troopers who organize a
resistance sell to subvert the
first order, but from the insomnia.
Remember the fins awakening is triggered
not by the death of some innocent
villager but by the death of his
friend. A fellow, a storm trooper.
Yeah.
This is the event that quite
literally leaves a mark on him
and yet the film quickly forgets
this key transformative moment
because minutes later we see
Finn Who's being an laughing,
what blasting his former teammates.
Now you might say that Finn and the rest
of the resistance are acting in self
defense and you'd be right.
I mean star wars is after all a story
about resistance and when faced with an
oppressive police or military force,
sometimes violence may be
necessary to achieve liberation,
but having to hurt one group of people
in order to help another is always a
tragic trade off even if it's necessary.
If there's a core message to fins,
Redemption Story in the force awakens
something that the film really wants us to
believe in,
it's that people can change
and if we accept that,
then the possibility must also exist
other storm troopers to change as well.
Now perhaps their transformation,
it's unlikely but not any more
unlikely than fins own awakening.
And isn't that the idea at the heart
of the original star wars trilogy,
I know there is good in you. The emperor
hasn't driven it from you fully at,
they're still exist. Good. Even
someone as evil as Darth Vader,
because if that's the case,
and I think it is,
and that means the fall of every storm
trooper represents the death of the
possibility of redemption,
the possibility of another fan.
If you'd like to see more long form video
essays that focus on the intersections
of entertainment and politics,
head over to my patrion page and help
fund the pop culture detective agency.
Yeah.